mr. know-it-all am i less of a man if I
use the automated parallel parking on my
Lexus it all depends if you're talking
about literally being less of a man I
mean are you singh at the thought
of being emasculated by your automobiles
bizarre self-sufficiency in that sense
you are by definition less of a man as
you have lost weight by accelerating
your secretion of moisture but if you're
talking figuratively you then fall into
the treacherous Bob that is a gender
role so American culture tells us a man
should indeed avoid assistance of any
kind while operating an automobile this
applies especially to help from
inanimate objects such as baths or even
help from an animate object such as a
passenger using said map to help you
navigate these are hard and fast
American values however if you come from
a culture with different gender roles
then relying on automated parallel
parking might be tolerated in that case
though I'd wonder how you procured
Alexis in the first place and if you're
even properly licensed to drive i'm mr.
know-it-all which means i already know
whether or not you are interested in
clicking on the subscribe button you are